if you want to cite instances of racism
that we can all find and fight together
that's something that i'm more than
willing to stand next to you and fight
because that's obviously stuff that we
should fight together but when you just
say that there is a white privilege out
there in the ether and that by dint of
birth your skin color generates for you
an advantage what you're really saying
to people is that you your view is less
valuable because you have not
experienced what i've experienced and
that is an identity argument that's a
character argument that's not a rational
political argument that can actually be
taken on in any way that's that's it's
more of a it's more of a cudgel and a
club than it is an attempt to open a
discussion